um all right so what else do you have uh
in the works or what are you planning in
terms of your content and everything Oh
and before I ask that I want to ask are
you just like totally [ __ ]
business-wise because I saw you were
like age restricted by the time the
entertain episode already went live and
no I think I broke even on that video
because you made some money before they
did that yeah okay so I think I broke
even maybe I made a little bit but it's
basically with because there is a
sponsorship
yeah so
um but do they get you a lot no really
that was like I mean sometimes but for
the most part no they would get me more
when I did rap reactions oh that was
hell that was like every video
demonetized really yeah just because it
was like violent [ __ ] or what
um it was like the Music Company oh well
that's like copyright yeah yeah so I
like I got like 20 000 subscribers in a
day or 10 000 and
um I like I just stopped doing it
because I like would make no money on
the videos yeah but that's a wild side
of YouTube where the like reaction
Channels with millions of views of like
people reacting to music and they're not
making money on any of the videos but
then they find other ways to make money
I I never did I just was like F this I'm
gonna go a different route I feel you
but all right so new new ideas for the
content or where is it going from here
oh um I just started wife School
so it's like basically me learning
things to like be more traditional
pretty much so
um the first episode was helping me pick
out better clothes a little bit
um and the second one is me learning how
to make a cake from scratch and
um how what did I cook it was it was
like stir fry or something so it's like
the second episode is cooking next
episode
um what are we gonna do for episode
three I don't even remember oh they
wanted me to go on dates with guys but
get feedback from the guys like they're
not even gonna be on camera or like film
a date or anything but like just talk to
the guys and be like what did you think
of pearl so
um I could know like if I'm being
feminine I guess on dates if you went on
dates with like 100 guys you feel like
what what percentage of them would you
like be interested in a second date oh
gosh well I mean what are the
prerequisites for the date just like
um like like randomly or are they like
because because she like that's a good
point because she'll Peck him out and be
like do you think like he's cute yeah
there's got to be some degree of
selection because if you're bringing me
some like 50 year old lady I'm just
gonna be like no yeah I mean I don't I
don't know if I'm even gonna do that
episode we'll see
um I don't know if you find love on the
internet what could be better than that
for the world to see yeah I don't know
we'll see for sure but that was an idea
we had
um and then I was gonna do I'm gonna go
to this girl in Florida where she lives
like so oh my gosh I I couldn't live
like that like she's crazy traditional
like she like does her laundry by hand
but I'm gonna like live like her for a
week and see how it goes nice
um
yeah
so is that something you aspire to
though to be so traditional that you're
doing laundry by hand it seems like a
massive waste of time no I won't be that
sure no I mean I just it's more just
about the whole point of the series is
to listen to what men want and try to be
more of what men want so that's that's
the whole point uh is it like to do
laundry by hand no but like sometimes
you learn like how to make something
like I don't know I didn't realize like
how how much men value cooking and even
like I'm in my dad like a cake from
scratches just he like thought it was
the sweetest thing throughout my life
very few girls ever cooked for me and
for sure whenever they did I felt like
it was usually a pretty genuine sign of
them like wanting to be with me and that
definitely like with my girl the first
time she cooked for me was around the
same time that I sort of started to like
realize like oh she loves you like she
really like wants the best for you and
she'll do anything for you and for sure
like I mean on the most basic biological
level I feel like cooking for somebody
is just kind of like providing for them
like and especially if it's decent you
know yeah for me I can't cook I'm
ordering Postmates I'll make you eggs in
the morning if you want that's about all
I got going for me yeah yeah but that's
the whole point of life school I'm like
um she's also going to talk about just
like the mentality that you should have
as a wife so like like why are you guys
looking for problems like he might be
cheating he might not but like why are
you guys like like literally looking for
Pro and just like stuff like that when
it talks more about I'm like kind of
butchering it but she was just telling
me about it but she like literally
trains like women to be wives and like
managing because a lot of times girls
want a guy that makes a lot of money
because they want a lifestyle but they
don't know how to be like Frugal and she
was saying that she could raise kids on
like 500 bucks a month or less all right
Andrew Tate said that too and I was like
hey what well think about it like what
do you need you need food private school
okay but that's that's a lifestyle
Choice yeah yeah so that like goes back
to like even just like basic [ __ ] I feel
like a kid is going to cost way more
than that yeah I mean if you if you
wanted to but if you wanted to yeah but
I don't want to give my kid a [ __ ]
Somalian upbringing here in Beverly
Hills yeah I mean that's fine but the
cost to raise a kid out here like
average kid like even if you're not like
on some rich [ __ ] at all like I don't
know yeah
no I mean I I agree like with that
Debbie if you want your kid to live a
certain type of Lifestyle you absolutely
have to make a certain amount of money
but but the truth is that every girl
can't get a guy that's that rich so you
have to figure out a way to make it work
you gotta get BBL
not you but like in general that seems
to be the plan for most of these girls
when I go to the club in Miami I'm like
these [ __ ] just get bbls and just
stand around
and just hope some dude's gonna be hyped
on them it's like the weirdest most
transparent [ __ ] Dynamic on Earth
well you know it must work if they're
doing it
yeah I'd like to some extent I mean
maybe it's just attention and not like
getting an actual ring but but attention
is step one yeah you got to get some
attention before there could be any
chance of that right yeah I guess I
guess that's true I mean like as much as
women like make their faces look weird
and like do all the whatever the world
has changed yeah but like there's a part
of me that always is thinking like well
there's a reason they're doing it like I
don't think girls would do it at all if
like like they weren't getting sexual
attention from it yeah yeah I mean both
both sides lie about that [ __ ] like
girls get lip fillers and then guys say
I don't care about lip fillers but then
every [ __ ] girl knows that they get
more attention with lip fillers
yeah yeah and guys say we don't like
makeup and then every girl knows that
they're gonna basically be ignored by
dudes if they don't wear makeup to the
club yeah
dudes just are in denial about what
they're actually into if a dude tells me
I don't like makeup on the podcast I
just like laugh in their face because
it's like you're just lying to me yeah
yeah I mean I do think like men in
general prefer more maybe maybe I'm
biased but I think they prefer a more
natural look for like long term but see
this is the thing is that
all right I had a friend who
was a bartender at this bar right and
I'm talking to him and he he was on
steroids at one point and put on like 40
pounds of muscle or whatever and I was
under the impression because I've been
actually believing women my whole life
that women weren't into that kind of
thing and I'm like so when you were
super [ __ ] gigantic
did you get like less attention from
girls he's like what he's like bro it's
like I had a [ __ ] sign on my forehead
saying suck my dick because every single
girl that would look at me you know if
it like and I'm sure you probably are
not super attracted to like a guy that's
like massive steroid looking ass dude
right I would assume you as an average
woman you're probably but at the end of
the day those dudes are getting
attention in a way where that even if a
small percentage of those women convert
into sex partners those dudes are
getting so much more sex as a result of
looking like this total freak than a
normal guy even though the a normal
woman would tell you that she wants a
normal guy well girls we also don't know
what we want they actually they actually
say that women prefer fat guys with
muscles over skinny guys like because I
think it boils down to protection if the
dude's that big like you think you think
he can protect you I know Fighters will
say it's not all about that I mean look
I don't I'm just saying what it looks
like as a girl I don't meet a lot of
women who who say like I need a guy with
really really low body fat percentage
but at the same time all the guys I know
who have like chiseled [ __ ] jaw lines
and ripped at abs and stuff are drowning
in [ __ ] because if they take their
[ __ ] shirt off and take a photo and
put it on Instagram their DMS Are Gonna
Fill Up with chicks because that just
grabs attention you know well I mean I
would argue that men have worse beauty
standards than women like like they
always talk about like women have these
high beauty standards blah blah blah
it's like it's like men actually have
higher beauty standards I mean women's
swipe right on dating apps five percent
of the time and you could argue oh that
well that's superficial okay let's let's
quadruple it let's make it 20 of the
time you could even ask women you could
ask any women because I've done this
many times in my life it'd be like what
percentage of guys do you think that you
would want to sleep with or date or
whatever and they they say low numbers
they'll say 10 you know like they're
they're honest about that that the vast
majority of guys consider the vast
majority of women acceptable sex
partners and the vast majority of women
considered an incredibly small
percentage you guys acceptable sex
partners yeah and even if you make it
like relationship Partners like women
find 80 percent of men on as
unattractive eighty percent so it's like
are those 80 of them going to be that
picky or you make 50 like that picky
men's swipe right 45 50 of the time on
dating apps so it's like who who has the
higher beauty standards men or women men
easily and you know think about this
like think about how much a guy's body
fat percentage really matters is that
picture two different scenarios you're
gonna put a fat guy on the cover of a
magazine or you're gonna put a guy with
like a jacked guy with like [ __ ]
washer board six pack abs on the cover
of the magazine this is what they're
going to do for the guy's fat if they
put on the cover of the magazine because
I've been this guy before not on the
magazine cover but like doing like a
photo shoot they
puts you in a bunch of designer clothes
they'll put designer on you they put
sunglasses on you they'll [ __ ] like
put some alcohol in the shot or like
some smoke or whatever basically like
whatever they can do to distract the
viewer from what you actually look like
but then if you're like in great shape
they're just gonna have you stand there
and that's it and they're not going to
have any [ __ ] props or whatever
because you don't need it and it's like
as a guy though to like to register as
physically attractive as a guy is
incredibly rare and difficult like it's
just like what percentage of guys are
walking around in super sick shape it's
just like I think five ten percent maybe
at most I think 80 of Americans are
overweight it's like 70 or I think it's
like 80 of women 70. so even right there
we're working with like 20 of the dudes
might be in good shape yeah yeah but I
don't know I feel like
the reason we have like this this group
of men that like
are not in good shape or like you know
what I'm saying like the they call them
like the
what do they say like the lack of
masculinity in men today basically I
think it's like women's fault to be
honest because it's like men are just
like the juice ain't worth the squeeze
anymore what am I doing all this for
it's just not even worth it to try yeah
I'm glad I didn't get that idea into my
head as a young guy like the the notion
that like well getting [ __ ] is really
hard so maybe you should just say [ __ ]
it and just give up yeah I'm glad I
never had that cross my mind I don't
think you should but again it's just
like I I think like women have changed
more today than men but it says a lot
about the lack of self-control of a
young man because when I think about it
I knew even as a young dude that being
in really really good shape was probably
the best thing that I could do to
improve my chances of getting girls that
were like more attractive than me or
more attractive than where I was at
right then and I still didn't do it I
still never got like sick shade because
I was just lazy and [ __ ]
self-absorbed and just like didn't have
the discipline I guess you know and when
I think about it now when I'm like super
hardcore on the like Diet weight loss
grind or whatever I'm just like this
would have been so much more
advantageous if you did this at like 21
instead of 39. I wouldn't have had to
screw so many fat chicks yeah but I'm
kind of glad I took some of those lumps
you know
like I remember one time like 2012 when
like the iPhone camera first started to
get good that like I was drunk as [ __ ]
in the club and just made out of this
[ __ ] super fat Mexican girl and then
like I think like went back and got a
[ __ ] from her or whatever but one of
my friends filmed me and sent to the
group chat and that was the first time
that I ever had like my my drunken bar
Antics exposed to all my friends and
that's when I realized like you should
probably you can't keep doing this that
was your rock bottom well just the
realization that because that was like
social media step one because like if
there's no video It Doesn't Matter yeah
nobody cares if somebody's like oh out
of mid I was some ugly girl it's like
whatever yeah but as soon as there's a
video is it still out there I mean
nobody would even care but they could
pay buddy you're gonna be on patreon go
on his patreon you wouldn't even believe
it was me it was so pixelated in
comparison to these days probably all
right I gotta pee um I appreciate you
coming on the show for sure and what's
the channel pearly things if they want
to tune in just pearly thinks that that
way search it up appreciate you thanks
for having me yeah for sure no jumper
coolest podcast on world Checkers on
YouTube Tick Tock patreon Instagram like
comment and subscribe nojumper.com if
you wanna support appreciate you as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible